welcome everyone this short screencast
is an overview of the experiment
protocol document this is the second
document on your way to the final paper
it's a somewhat unusual document but I
think it's really important in terms of
helping you and your teammates and your
Mentor get complete Clarity on what
you're going to achieve for the final
paper
the rationale at high level is the same
as the one for the lit review it's about
productive dialogue we want you in
productive dialogue with your teammates
and with yourself and with your mentor
about the scope of the project and its
overall goals
we want you to identify the core
questions you'll be addressing at this
stage we want you to identify your core
methods that is data models metrics and
everything that goes along with that and
maybe most importantly for this phase we
want you to identify obstacles and
propose some workarounds the more the
merrier in terms of uncovering these
things that are threatening the
convergence of the project if we can
identify these things at this stage we
can probably find really productive
workarounds but as it gets closer and
closer to the final paper deadline it
becomes harder and harder to get these
things to converge in a happy way
the requirements are linked from the
course website you can see the link at
the top here let me just offer a quick
rundown
this is a short structured report that
is establishing your core experimental
framework and kind of talking about it I
emphasize short they can get long if you
have a lot of obstacles or points of
uncertainty but by and large if things
are going well we expect this to be a
short document we do specify that the
max is eight pages but I'll say that the
norm is for them to be shorter than that
we have as before an optional overleaf
template this is just derived from the
ACL templates we encourage you to use it
but it is not required at this stage
and then we come to the required pieces
I mentioned these in the lit review
overview we want you to now to State
your core hypothesis or hypotheses as
clearly as possible
we want you to talk about what data
resources that you're going to use and
any limitations access limitations
producing data is a big limitation
anything that might threaten the need
that you have for data
metrics this is important if it's a
standard sort of classification problem
it might be a very short thing that you
report like you say macro F1 but if
you're working on a specialized problem
or inventing your own metrics this might
be a more detailed discussion
models of course or architectures we
want to know about the baselines that
you plan the comparison points the
ablations all of that stuff and we would
like to see how it Keys into the core
hypotheses you listed in 4A
and then the general reasoning how does
the project come together how do the
data and the models and the metrics
connect with the hypothesis I think
that's the most important thing most
powerful thing to convey at that point
and then a summary of progress so far
I emphasize you are not required to have
any results at this stage it could be
purely a planning document but if you do
have results it's great to report them
that's kind of evidence that you've got
a minimal viable project and it we can
start to build on whatever insights
those results have offered but it's not
required but we would like to know what
you've done so far even if it's just
assembling the raw ingredients let us
know if you've run some experiments and
you got stuck that's an obstacle that
we'll want to identify that is the
spirit of this progress report it's not
evaluative in terms of us giving you a
grade based on how far along you are
quite the contrary this is entirely
evaluated based on the extent to which
you can give us a clear insight into how
you're doing for this project
and then finally as always required
references section in terms of tips I
would say first there's no particular
length we have in mind a short or a long
rubric could be bad or good depending on
the state of your project and what
you're trying to achieve so completely
open-minded about that
as I said before please try to call out
concerns you have even if they are
distant ones this is meant to be a last
chance to make sure the project will
converge in the time allotted so you
might as well err on the side of more
disclosures
yes you need to be able to State a
hypothesis it is common for engineers to
come to me and say but I don't have a
hypothesis all I want to do is see
whether this model is a good model for
my problem and I say to them that is a
hypothesis just state that as a claim
about what you think will work and that
will actually guide us intellectually
and also guide us in terms of choosing
baselines and ablation studies and other
things that will give us insight into
whether you're right about this thing
that you feel about this model that
you're evaluating
no you do not need to report results as
I said before but they are very welcome
because they're a sign that you've kind
of got all the working pieces in place
and the project machine is functioning
we want you to have a full working
pipeline pipeline as soon as possible it
is I confess tempting to insist on
initial results so that that pipeline
would be in place I think that's
premature but the spirit of this is that
we want you basically to be at a state
where any day you could submit a project
it would be a working project it might
not be the one that you envisioned but
you could submit it once you get to that
point it's a really happy state in which
you're mainly just adding new
experimental results improving the
reporting adding analyzes and other
things that allow you to build a really
fleshed out project so get that minimal
viable project in the bag soon
so that you can do creative exploration
without feeling like you're under a lot
of undue pressure
for other tips and resources I have a
very large markdown document that covers
lots of things FAQs that I've seen in
the past
discussions of each one of the documents
that's associated with the final project
work examples of Past final papers that
have gone on after some work to be
Publications and a whole lot else
besides so if your start if you feel
like you just need some guidance on
crucial points about how to develop a
project in the space I highly recommend
this document I think it's got lots of
good stuff in it and
if your paper goes on to be a
publication I would love to hear about
it drop me a note and I will with your
permission add that to the list of
published papers stemming from work for
this course I'm very proud of how long
and diverse that list is